oh na na rihanna is pregnant
[Music]
the 33 year old singer is expecting her
first child with her beau rapper asap
rocky it's amazing riri debuts her bear
baby bump covered in colorful jewels and
vintage chanel body chains and the
singer's ensemble is equally on point
check out ree's pink coat and ripped
jeans while holding hands with her man
in the streets of his hometown harlem
new york i couldn't tell you how happy i
am a source tells et the photos were
taken early in the morning on january
29th
quote they are such night owls but they
wanted to shoot these pics discreetly it
was important for rihanna to make this
announcement on her terms she couldn't
really hide it any longer and turns out
the location of the photo shoot has a
special meaning our source says that
harlem quote brings them both comfort
and it's where they feel really at home
his upbringing in harlem shaped so much
of who he is and it hasn't always been
easy this was a happy milestone and it
felt right to shoot the photos where it
all started i'm honestly truly blessed
real you know and riri and asap well
they're over the moon about becoming
parents according to our source the
couple is feeling very blessed that
they're having a baby together although
they already considered themselves a
family having a baby makes their bond
even stronger quote they enjoyed keeping
the pregnancy a secret for as long as
they could but they're thrilled to be
able to share the news with their fans
she may never wear it but she save it so
our babies will be flyer than their
parents and the love from their celeb
pals is pouring in on social media like
nicki minaj get that popping the super
bass rapper shared riri's pregnancy
photos alongside the caption
congratulations ree cardi b and khloe
kardashian did the same the i like it
rapper writes omg congrats rihanna while
chloe says this makes me so happy it's
such a beautiful thing the pregnancy
announcement comes days after a source
told et that riri and asap are
inseparable quote their relationship is
in a good place after a very busy fall
with professional commitments they took
some time to relax and unwind and really
reconnect with each other as for asap he
always saw fatherhood in his future the
rapper told gq last may that he'd be
quote an incredible remarkably overall
amazing dad i would have a very fly
child and re she's always wanted kids
too the umbrella singer manifested her
future during a 2012 appearance on the
ellen degeneres show do you want kids
yes eventually i mean absolutely
would you do it alone or do you want to
wait till you're
in a relationship or married i mean i
would prefer
to have a you know a full family
i'm sure pretty sure i can handle it if
i had to
on my own but you know that's not what
i'm striving for